In this video we will compare
all the different methods
we have seen so far in
this course and review what
they are used for, their
benefits, and limitations.
Linear regression is used to
predict a continuous outcome.
Linear regression is
simple and commonly used,
and it works on small
and large data sets.
The downside is that it
assumes a linear relationship.
If we have a nonlinear
relationship,
we need to add variables
to our analysis.
For instance, suppose y =
a*log(X)+b, where x is data,
and y is what we
need to predict.
To be able to find the
coefficients a and b
through linear
regression, we need
to view log(X) as
a new variable.
Remember that we did this in
the Google homework problem.
Logistic regression is used to
predict a categorical outcome.
We mainly focused on binary
outcomes, like yes or no,
sell or buy, accept
or reject, and so on.
We have seen it applied to
predict the quality of care,
good or bad; the winner of
the US presidential election,
Republican or Democrat; parole
violation and loan payment, yes
or no.
In addition to its
relative simplicity,
logistic regression
computes probabilities
that can be used to assess the
confidence of our prediction.
The downside is again similar
to that of linear regression.
In the trees week
we learned CART,
which is used to predict
a categorical outcome,
with possibly more than two
categories, like quality
rating, from one to five,
and three decisions,
say, buy, sell, or hold.
It can also predict
a continuous outcome,
such as salary or price.
We have seen it
applied to predict
life expectancy, earnings
from census data,
and letter recognition.
The power of CART
lies in the fact
that it can handle
nonlinear relationships
between variables.
The tree representation makes it
easy to visualize and interpret
the results.
The downside is
that CART may not
work very well on
small data sets.
Random forest is
also used to predict
categorical outcomes
or continuous outcomes.
Its benefit over CART is that
it can improve the prediction
accuracy.
However, we need to
adjust many parameters
and it's not as easy
to explain as CART
This week, we learned
hierarchical clustering,
which is used to
find similar groups.
An important aspect
of clustering data
into smaller groups is that
we can improve our prediction
accuracy by applying
our predictive methods,
like logistic regression for
instance, on each cluster.
We expand on this
cluster-then-predict idea
in one of our homework problems.
Hierarchical clustering is
an attractive technique,
because we do not need to
select the number of clusters
before running the algorithm.
Also, we can visualize the
clusters using a dendrogram.
The drawback though, is
that hierarchical clustering
is hard to use on
large data sets,
because of the pairwise
distance calculation,
as we saw in this recitation.
An alternative method
is k-means clustering,
which works well on
data sets of any size.
However, k-means
requires selecting
the number of clusters
before running the algorithm.
This may not be a
limitation if we
have an intuition of the number
of clusters we want to look at,
as in the medical image
segmentation example.
I hope that this quick review
gave you a good refresher
before the competition week.
Good luck.